Ponemah is one of the richest people on
the planet though few in the West have
heard of him he's the CEO and co-founder
of 10 cent China's internet Colossus
about 1 billion people use 10 cents to
messaging apps WeChat and QQ for
everything
texting shopping playing games ordering
food taxis and more and that's just the
beginning
based in China's Silicon Valley Shenzhen
it has businesses in a vast range of
industries like gaming music news video
online publishing and cloud outside
China it has stakes in Tesla and
snapchat and financed Hollywood
blockbusters presiding over a tech
Empire so huge Ponemah is relatively
low-key and stays out of the media this
is how the show engineer mark created
one of the most influential tech
companies in the world if we had to
compare him with a Western equivalent
Mars probably most like Facebook's Mark
Zuckerberg this is Lulu Chen Bloomberg's
China technology reporter both were
thrust into the spotlight at a
relatively young age and have had to
adjust their vision personality and
skill sets drastically about turmoils
and crises that companies that penetrate
every aspect of people's lives the few
signs in Maz earliest suggest that the
teenager with an obsession in astronomy
would become a big fish so Ponemah was
known as somewhat of a geek among his
classmates he had a reputation for
hacking into university computers and
locking the hard drives even the admins
weren't able to unlock them
amah founded $0.10 at the age of 27 with
three college classmates and a friend
for their first product they cloned an
israeli-made instant messaging service
and adapted it for the Chinese market
what eating the other end of the old
young well pay the older
the free QQ messaging service secured
100,000 users by late 1999 but it also
required more money to keep it going
in 2010 sent almost went bankrupt but
was able to secure four million dollars
in funding to keep going but then came
the dot-com bust and money was hard to
get so in 2004 my decided to list $0.10
on the Hong Kong stock exchange raising
one hundred and eighty million dollars
to be honest the IPO wasn't exactly a
buzz a fall below is issuing share price
within a month but $0.10 hadn't even big
a problem
it had developed a reputation as the
king of knockoffs and it couldn't shake
the reputation of being a copycat
at one point its reputation felt so low
it was embroiled in a full-blown media
controversy and peers openly accused and
scolded it for violating copyrights the
real breakthrough for $0.10 came in
January 2011 with the birth of WeChat
WeChat was created in just two months
timing was key
mass or the coming of the mobile
internet age and WeChat was launched
just at the moment when smartphone sales
in China took off
WeChat now has almost 1 billion monthly
active users 3 times the entire
population of the u.s. at first the
service only allowed users to send text
messages like whatsapp then it added a
voice message function and then it's
moments function a page resembling
Facebook's newsfeed and it evolved into
a social media app the most important
breakthrough for WeChat came in 2014
that year it introduced a feature that
allowed users to send virtual red
envelopes filled with money
electronically an age-old custom in
China during the holidays and at special
occasions they became a hit users
quickly started linking their bank
accounts with WeChat wallet now we Chad
as a force that even shakes traditional
banks and financial institutions
you can almost pay everything through
WeChat it's also one of the main reasons
China's becoming a cashless society
WeChat is Held's unique
Chinese innovation but many dissidents
deem it a government surveillance app
because it collects huge amount of data
on users for the Chinese ruling party
it's both appealing and daunting it
opens a window to understanding the
psyche of the people they rule like
never before but they also are wary of a
company like $0.10 that's why you see
constant and regular crackdowns on them
$0.10 is grown into a tech behemoth with
a market capitalization of nearly half a
trillion US dollars with the success of
WeChat it was able to change from
copycat to innovator Ponemah has also
stepped out of his shell a lot he's
still low-key compared with other
internet founders with flair but you can
also see him becoming a more vocal
leader and strategist $0.10 is broken
into markets like Southeast Asia and
India but it hasn't cracked the Western
markets Mars ambition to become a global
player might still be a tough road to
take
you
you